soignée et être rentables voilà le
casse-tête de l'hôpital public depuis 40
ans certains dénoncent un
hôpital-entreprise clients ce concept
émergent à la fin des années 70 le
système hospitalier français déjà dans
une logique d'économie à cette époque
l'hôpital public que se trouve dans la
même situation que les entreprises
privées c'est à dire qu'il y as parking
dans la crise économique de poser les
mêmes questions d'entreprises privées où
va l'argent pourquoi il est dépensé
qu'il a dépensée à partir des années 80
cela se traduit par des fermetures de
services de lee ou des suppressions de
postes comme à saint mihiel dans la
meuse sur le point de se séparer de son
service de chirurgie je suis chirurgien
le temps mais j'essaie 20 84 g mais
s'est jamais posé le problème est ce que
je suis un tableau pas dans les années
90 avec le déficit croissant de la
sécurité sociale il faut encore faire
des économies la gestion financière de
l'hôpital public devient plus rigoureuse
difficile pour le personnel médical
d'appréhender cette gestion d'entreprise
comme l'expliquent ce professeur en 1995
je ne connais pas le coût exact de cet
instrument bistouri électrique mais on
ne sait pas non plus exactement le coût
que représente toutes les personnes ici
qui participent à l'intervention en 2003
le plan hôpital 2007 et présenté par le
gouvernement une série de mesures pour
améliorer l'offre de soins d'un côté et
réduire les dépenses de santé de l'autre
début 2004
fait rare à l'époque sept syndicats
manifestent contre ce plan
la réforme qui est en cours c'est le
premier pas vers la privatisation est un
système néolibéral qui conduira à se
construire a évidemment et avant toute
chose ce camp le plus d'argent et les
autres pays font comme ils pourront
nouvelles réformes en 2000
8les directeur obtiennent plus de
pouvoir de décision là où avant les
maires et le personnel médical avait
plus de poids des médecins craignent des
décisions sur la seule base de la
rentabilité comme la fermeture de
services
la loi bachelot veut transformer la
gestion l'hôpital en gestion
entrepreneuriales basé sur l'idée de la
rentabilité financière
c'est pour ça qu'on veut donner tout le
pouvoir un directeur en 2018 la ministre
de la santé reconnaît que la gestion
entrepreneuriales avait pris trop de
place dans l'hôpital on était dans un
système qui devenait qui s'était emballé
quelque part et donc je souhaite qu'on
change totalement de logiciels mais dans
les faits rien ne semble bouger les
revendications des personnels sont
toujours les mêmes
[Musique]